so toyotaro is considered a bad dude for
this
but have you seen this holy [ __ ] do i
have a lot to say on this one
for those of you out there that saw the
title of this video and thought that
maybe i titled it unfairly and without
thinking
i mean i had other titles in mind but
this seemed to be the nicest
i'm always going to try to be honest
with you guys and if this video has any
moral to take away from it it's that
lying is bad
and trust me i'll get to that but yes
this video is about dragon ball
successor manga dragon ball super
or as some people like to call it joe
but they don't even call it that in
japan what's wrong with you
now i have been fair to the super manga
in the past the heck
some of my most popular videos have been
about the manga and what i thought it's
been doing right
however this won't be one of those
videos no
i wanted to give toyotaro a chance i i
really did
but to tell you the truth it's been
pretty bad for a while now
but the last few chapters have been
particularly atrocious
so let's get into it alright so
first things first toyotaro is no akira
toriyama and that right there was the
very reason why i didn't want to harshly
judge the manga's quality early on
that is until enough time had passed for
toyotaro to fully settle into the role i
mean you wouldn't judge a brand new
professional fighter for having a shaky
start even if his trainer was floyd
mayweather
everyone's human and everyone needs a
chance to find their groove
so i figured i would give toyotaro that
same courtesy i mean if we really look
at it he's following one of the most
celebrated mangakas
ever while carrying on the manga
representing one of the most popular
franchises
in history not just one of the most
popular animes ever
one of the most popular franchises
period
looking at dragon ball's video game
sales and super's recent merch sales
will tell you
everything you need to know about that
so to cut a long story short because i'm
sure you all know the situation already
toei wanted to make a new dragon ball
anime and manga akira toriyama was kind
of on board with the idea
but was more likely to take up shark
juggling than to start illustrating a
manga again
so toy was like don't worry i got you
fam we can pick a few people to audition
and you can choose your successor
toriyama must have liked the idea
because soon after the world of dragon
ball was introduced to a bouncing baby
toyotaro
only he's not a baby or bouncing but
he is toyotaro some of you might even
have heard of him from his unofficial
dragon ball fanfic dragon ball af
where he went by the name of toibo
everything seemed to be going great for
toyotaro he was carrying on the legacy
of toriyama's manga he was an enormous
fan of the series growing up
and toriyama himself chosen believing
that he had something
special yessiree things were going
smoothly until
in may of 2018 toyotaro posted this
sketch
on his twitter a number of days later
this image surfaced online
with evidence of toyotaro tracing
sections of the captain america
character because of this a large number
of fans decided to go back through the
super manga to see if there were any
other traced parts this is what they
found
a large number of heavily referenced
images from the old dragon ball manga
sources this for a large number of fans
was used as further reason to bolster
their argument that toyotaro
was a bad mangaka but let me ask you a
question
do you or anyone you know own a copy of
iron marshall
no how about this have you even heard
of this comic i personally hadn't until
i began writing this video
but it's something i think puts this
argument into perspective
for instance if i was to put these two
images side by side
what would you say now i know what
you're thinking
that looks like all mine but other than
that they look sort of similar right
now if i was to tell you that that iron
marshall chapter was published in 1989
and that image of dragon ball was
published in 1991
what would you say then to me that looks
heavily referenced but it's definitely
not
traced toriyama clearly drew that
himself but the framing and poses are
all copied
piccolo's foot legs hand positioning
pretty much everything in this image was
copied from the iron marshall comic
and toyotaro referencing earlier
material for posing
isn't something that's new to the
franchise dragon ball has been
cannibalizing itself for decades
now so i think pegging toyotaro's
originality as the main reason why
people should label him as a
bad mangaka i think at least is wrong
so if referencing isn't an issue and
toriyama did it too
then toyotaro aside from the captain
america trace should be considered a
great manga car right
no no no
not by a long shot the real bread and
butter to the manga game has
and always will be composition and
pacing
style can only get you so far for those
of you out there that don't know what
that is
it's the author's ability to frame and
position the characters and panels on a
given page to encourage
further reading put more simply it's the
imagination one possesses to create an
interesting looking page that's easy to
read
and if you require an even simpler
explanation men make
cool pictures what read more
excuse me and with dragon ball being one
of the highest selling mangas of all
time you better believe akira toriyama
understood these principles and
implemented them in extremely effective
ways
so let's just say there was a standard
that needed to be met with the super
manga
and i think this interview with bo
toriyama and toyotaro present
was telling to say the least toriyama
when speaking on what toyotaro could
stand to improve upon said
let's see if i had to say something else
then i guess it's that you're too
careful particularly with battle scenes
it might actually be good to cut corners
a bit
toyotaro responds battle scenes are
really difficult and i'm always fretting
over them
to which toriyama finishes with i had
trouble drawing fights too
but sometimes drawing them with a rough
touch can produce good results oddly
enough
that's why it's important to cut corners
that'll be perfect
and then toyotaro responds i'll keep
that in mind
oh and uh spoiler alert he doesn't keep
that in mind
it's a shame he didn't heed this warning
because in this instance toriyama summed
up toyotaro's problems perfectly
he's asking you to do less work why
can't do that
sorry about that to better illustrate my
point though here are two pages
the page on the left is from akira
toriyama's dragon ball manga and the one
on the right is from a recent chapter of
toyotaro's dragon ball super manga
what's the difference between these two
pages i ask you or better yet
which one would you be more inclined to
read you might not know why but you're
probably inclined to choose toriyama's
one right
and in short here's why there's too much
[ __ ] going on in toyotaro's one
too many pointless panels and too much
being said that ultimately amounts to
nothing there's a time and place for
everything and that
isn't it if you look at toriyama's first
page you can see that it's simple
offers little to read and occupies the
page with larger detail images to convey
what's going on
and above all else finishes on a hook
and or cliffhanger you'll find that in a
toriyama manga that practically every
page
ends in a cliffhanger of sorts something
that teases you to turn the page to see
what happens next
something i also want to draw attention
to are toriyama's use of reaction shots
let's count the amount of reaction shots
in this scuffle with napa and goku
in 12 pages there are five
panels featuring commentary from other
characters five
now if i was to look at the vegeta fight
with jiren in chapter 40 of dragon ball
super
how many reaction shots do you think
i'll find well i'm glad you asked
in 8 pages there were 9 reaction shots
with and without commentary
4 fewer pages and almost twice the
reaction shots
but why is that an issue i hear you
asking because they make pages look way
too [ __ ] crowded
within these eight pages toyotaro drew i
liked
one panel this one why because it was
the only one given room to breathe
and what do i mean by giving room to
breathe by that i am referring
to the space and composition of a given
image or page
in a toriyama manga his panels can be
seen and understood at a glance
the same is not true for toyotaro's
manga you kind of have to look at it and
figure out what's going on in a sense
a lot of this is due to toyotaro
bloating his chapters with
unnecessary panels again this goes back
to that bit of advice toriyama gave to
toyotaro about cutting corners
less is more the readers only need
so much detail the rest is filler for
instance let's take a look at that
toriyama napa versus goku sequence again
how many panels were there used in 8
pages of it
the answer 30. in toyotaro's 8 pages
he uses 54 panels in the same amount of
pages
toyotaro uses almost twice the amount of
panels toriyama elected to use
and it shows everything looks so crammed
together
there are no big page spreads nothing is
given room to breathe
except this i like this and to prove
that it's not impossible
i someone who has no experience writing
or drawing a manga
will attempt to fix three pages from
toyotaro's one
these three pages were taken from the
beginning of chapter 38.
by the way if i was to really do this
i'd start from scratch drawing these
poses making sure the panels fit the way
i want them to
but we can't always have it our way can
we toyotaro so
let's begin the first page had way too
much going on to establish a scene
and again these reaction shots are not
needed
so this is what i did with the space i
reorganized a few things and kept it
simple i
only used what was needed to get the
point across to the reader as a result
more people get to appreciate this nice
drawing of kale
and they are not bored instead of
scanning through six panels
there are just two i pretty much do the
same thing for the remaining two pages
i remove what i think is unnecessary and
i think this works better
at least you won't get exhausted reading
it i really want to end on a positive
note but
i can't pretend that this is okay ever
since the future trunks act was
completed the dragon ball super manga
has gone into a complete and unmitigated
nose
dive in terms of quality there are
literal chapters going by now where i
can say
i didn't like a single drawing either
because it wasn't given enough room to
breathe
or because it lacked a basic
understanding of anatomy
or perspective or he ended up using the
same pose
30 000 times now don't get me wrong the
guy can draw dragon ball
in specific ways but the very fact he
lacks a base
in gestural drawing and anatomic
illustration is made evident with
quite a few of his pieces again he can
draw dragon ball well
but the likelihood of him showing us
something interesting on a regular basis
is highly doubtful because of his
limited experience
as for the story all i have to say is
this
in one chapter kale knocks out most of
the universes without so much as an
acknowledgement to their characters
it's truly something oh
also this yeah that happens too
look guys the dragon ball super manga is
behind the anime
so there's no new information to gather
from it in terms of plot it's rushing
all of its major plot points making
nothing feel important
and finally its composition and artwork
is either unimaginative
or cluttered up to my goddamn eyeballs
i'm sorry i genuinely loved the original
dragon ball manga
i read the entire thing in a single week
and have done multiple times
but this this was just incredibly
disappointing i mean in theory toyotaro
on the dragon ball super manga should
have worked
but that's just theory talk i mean
theoretically speaking if muhammad is
the most common first name in the world
and wang is the most common last name
then theoretically speaking muhammad
wang is the most common name on planet
earth but i can't assure you of that
i'm joking i can't assure you of
anything i can barely assure my car
you're supposed to insure your car
assuring it isn't a thing
huh oh anyway point being if it works in
theory it isn't always gonna work in the
real world
and toyotaro being dragon ball super's
manga artist was a nice theory
but in practice it's truly lackluster
and at worst
embarrassingly bad make sure to leave me
your reaction to the dragon ball super
manga down below in the comment section
do you think i was being fair or do you
think i was being too harsh on toyotaro
i can't wait to read what you think as
always i've been totally not mark
thank you so much for watching